Confidential Computing protects your data in
use through hardware based trusted execution
environments, otherwise called enclaves, but
how do you adopt these secure enclaves to
truly protect your applications end to end?
How does this align with your container or
Kubernetes strategy? And do you need new skills
or additional DevOps workflows to adopt them?
Hi, I am Pratheek Karnati, Security Architect
for IBM Cloud. Today, we are going to talk about
Confidential Computing, and specifically, how
easy it is to adopt TEEs and to protect your
cloud workloads using IBM Cloud Data Shield.
Briefly, let’s talk about Confidential Computing…
At a high-level confidential computing protects
data through encryption and isolation of memory,
which complements your data in transit encryption
(using TLS) and at rest encryption (envelope
encryption using a root key) for a true end
to end data protection. And this cryptographic
isolation of memory happens either at VM or
at process level. You can think of it as a
VM level cryptographic isolation or a process
level cryptographic isolation. For today, let’s
focus on process level cryptographic solutions…
…or secure enclaves… let’s look at Intel Software
Guard Extensions (SGX) and how Data Shield can
help you adopt Intel SGX with no code changes!
Intel Software Guard Extensions (SGX) is a set
of security-related instruction codes that are
built into some modern Intel central processing
units (CPUs). They allow user-level as well
as operating system code to define private regions
of memory, again enclaves, whose contents are
protected and unable to be either read or saved by
any process outside the enclave itself, including
processes running at higher privilege levels.
So, where do you begin?
First, you start with the Kubernetes cluster. You
can provision either an IBM Kubernetes Service
or Red Hat Open Shift on IBM Cloud cluster
with Intel SGX capable worker nodes. Next,
you install Data Shield helm chart on your
cluster. This installs your own dedicated
single tenant Data Shield instance on your
cluster, which includes an UI and an API.
The API seamlessly aligns with your cloud
native strategy and integrates with your
DevOps pipelines to convert your container images
to Intel SGX capable secure enclave counterparts,
using industry’s best Runtime Encryption
technology from Fortanix! Data Shield pulls
your container image from your registry, converts
and pushes the new image back to your registry,
without you having to make any code changes! You
can now update your Kubernetes deployment yaml
and deploy your new runtime memory
encrypted application to your cluster.
And yes, Data Shield also takes the
complexity away from attestation
and presents you the attestation report
through a Public Key Infrastructure native to
your cluster. This gives you the additional
layer of technical assurance you need.
The UI helps with user access management,
presents you with the attestation reports,
gives you privileges to allow or deny a certain
enclave, and even has an intuitive tool to convert
your application for a quick demo or a PoC.
To recap, Data Shield is a single tenant
software that runs on your Kubernetes cluster
and helps you adopt Intel SGX secure enclaves
with technical assurance through attestation
reports and with no code changes.